ça fait du bien de sortir un peu un
événement à wallon jean yves caullet va
devoir repartir en campagne s'il veut
garder son fauteuil de maire élu à
chaque fois au premier tour lors de ses
précédents mandats il lui faut cette
fois ci passer par un second tour mais
lui niveau annie camoufler ni désaveu
des électeurs à la première fois qu'
avec quatre listes au scrutin et quatre
listes sa et par pays davantage des voix
donc c'est un petit peu plus compliqué
de faire une élection en un seul tour
ceci étant il a manqué comme vous le
savez - de prendre voix avec un taux
d'abstention de plus de 57% le premier
tour des municipales n'a pas passionné
les avallonnais
bien sûr le contexte et la crise du coc
vides peuvent en partie expliquer mais
j'arrive collet brigue aussi un
quatrième mandat lors des deux premiers
il était ps nrm lors du troisième il se
présente aujourd'hui sans éthique
essoufflement de son électorat volonté
de changement le maire réfute l'idée du
mandat de trop et se veut à l'écouté de
ses électeurs
ça ne fera le quatrième mandat que si
les avallonnaise les avallonnais me font
confiance
ça n'est pas un homme seul qui se
présente c'est une équipe
notre équipe est renouvelée à plus de la
moitié avec des jeunes actifs le maire
sortant aura face à lui la liste emmenée
par sonia pas tour et avec plus de 35%
au premier tour la candidate
l heure est arrivée en seconde position
sur sa liste figure andré villiers avec
elle pose sur les tracts de campagne le
député de la circonscription est
omniprésent lors de ces élections
sonia pas tour et elle revendique son
indépendance qu andré villiers
soutiennent notre projet c'est une chose
après me dire que je suis la candidate
d'andré villiers s'est pas tout à fait
le cas donc andré villiers est présent
il nous soutient
mais cette
ce n'est pas la liste d'andré villiers
être présent au second tour est déjà une
victoire selon la candidate de droite
surtout dans un tel contexte où faire
campagne et très compliqué oui c'est
complexe et notamment quand on est une
liste qui se présente qui est challenger
parce qu'on considère qu'on n'a pas de
légitimité à parler en tout cas c'est le
message qu'on nous fait sentir et rien
que cela c'est très complexe
une troisième liste celle du
rassemblement national mené par fanny
bouvier sera également présente au
second tour
aucun de ses représentants ne s'est
rendu disponible pour répondre à nos
questions